Hallo Deutschschule, Aussprache
Diphtonge, au / ei - ai / eu - äu
Das Ei
Das Huhn legt ein Ei.
Im Supermarkt kaufe ich immer frischeBio-Eier.
Zum Frühstück esse ich entweder ein Spiegelei oder ein Rührei.
Wasfindest du besser? Spiegelei oder Rührei?
das Haus
Ein Haus füreine Familie nennt man Einfamilienhaus.
Ein Haus für mehrere Familien nennt manMehrfamilienhaus.
Ein Haus auf einem Baum nenntman Baumhaus.
Ein Haus in dem man Urlaub macht,nennt man Ferienhaus.
Ein Haus, das sehr hochist, nennt man Hochhaus.
Wo wohnst du?
In einemHaus oder in einer Wohnung?
der Euro
Der Euro ist eine Währung wie Dollar, Rubel oderYen.
In Deutschland bezahlt man mit dem Euro.
Wie heißt die Währung in deinem Land?
der Hai
Der Hai schwimmt im Pazifischen Ozean.
Es gibt viele spannende Kinofilme mit gefährlichen Haien.
Hast du schon mal einen echten Hai gesehen?
der Daumen
Daumen, Zeigefinger, Mittelfinger,
Ringfinger, kleiner Finger.
Daumenhoch für alle Deutschlerner :)
Seit wann lernst du Deutsch?
die Eule
Die Eule sitzt auf einem Baum.
Harry Potter hat eine Eule namens Hedwig.
Hast du eigentlich ein Buch von Harry Pottergelesen?
das Eis
Ich hätte gerne 3 Kugeln Eis in der Waffel,bitte.
Oder nehme ich doch lieber einen Eisbecher?
Oder vielleicht dann doch eher ein Eis am Stiel?
Welche Eissorte findest du am besten?
der Bauch
Oh nein, mein Bauch tut weh, ich habe Bauchschmerzen!
Oh man, ich habe heute einfach zu viel gegessen!
der Läufer
Der Läufer läuft einen Marathonlauf.
Man sagt entweder "joggen" oder "laufen".
Ich gehe heute nach der Arbeit eine Runde joggen.
Ich gehe heute nach der Arbeit eine
Runde laufen.
Gehst du auch gerne laufen?
das Seil
BeimBergsteigen sorgt ein Seil für die Sicherheit.
Bei dem Abstieg vom Berg muss ich mich "abseilen".
Mein neues Fitnessprogramm heißt "Seilspringen".
Machst du eigentlich auch Fitnessübungen?
der Bauer
Als Bauer lebe ich auf meinem eigenen Bauernhof.
Am liebsten fahre ich mit meinem
roten Traktor über den Bauernhof.
Neun
9+9-9 = 9
9 / 19 / 99 / 999 / 9.999 / 99.999
Was ist deine Lieblingszahl?
reiten
Die Reiterin reitet auf einem braunen Pferd.
Wenn man mit einem Pferd springt, dann nenntman das Springreiten.
Und jetzt kommt Goethe:
Wer reitet so spät durch Nacht und Wind?
Es ist der Vater mit seinem Kind.
Weißt du, wie diesesGedicht von Goethe heißt?
das Auto
Ein Haus in dem man sich ein neues Autokaufen kann, nennt man Autohaus.
Ich habe einen neuen Job als Autoverkäufer in einemAutohaus.
Was ist dein Job? Wo arbeitest du?
die Verkäuferin, der Verkäufer
Die Verkäuferin verkauft luxuriöse Damenmode.
Der Verkäufer verkauftLebensmittel in seinem Kiosk.
Ein Kiosk ist ein Mini-Supermarkt
für Snacks, Zigaretten und Alkohol.
In Berlin heißt der Kiosk "Späti".
Kennst du auch einen Kiosk in deiner Nähe?
die Gitarrensaite
Bei einer Gitarre gibt es 6 verschiedene Gitarrensaiten.
Mit den sogenannten "Wirbeln" stimmt man die Saiten der Gitarre.
Kennst du jemanden der Gitarre spielen kann?
der Autor
Der Autorsucht nach einer Idee für seinen neuen Roman.
Am liebsten schreibt der Autor seine Romane in seinem Auto.
Was ist dein Lieblingsbuch?
das Feuer
das Feuerzeug
der Feuerlöscher
die Feuerwehr
das Feuerwerk
Die Notrufnummer bei einem Feuer ist 112.
eins, zwei, drei
ein Hund, zwei Hunde, drei Hunde
ein Bier, zwei Biere, drei Biere
eins + zwei + drei = sechs
Kannst du eigentlich auf Deutsch zählen?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf,sechs, sieben, acht, neun, zehn.
und rückwärts
Zehn, neun, acht, sieben,sechs, fünf, vier, drei, zwei, eins.
Super!
Abonniere den Kanal der Hallo Deutschschule
und aktiviere das kleine Glöckchen.
Gib uns jetzt einen Daumen nach oben
und klicke auf diesePlaylist für weitere Videos zum Deutschlernen.